du jour au lendemain gilles hénault
n'est petit village du loiret devient
l'unique héritier d'une vieille dame
fortunée notre budget de 650 1000 à 700
milles donc un million s'améliore de
budget on l'a appris par le notaire qui
nous a envoyé une lettre en disant qu'on
était les héritiers de cette dame
bon je vous dis sans surprise parce
qu'on savait un petit peu mais c'est une
bonne nouvelle quoi alors on voudrait
bien de tenter une cause la bonne
nouvelle s'appelle viol est fourni
cette habitante meurt en juin dernier à
90 ans avec son mari un banquier lui
aussi décédé il avait décidé de léguer
au village toute leur fortune leur
placement et leur maison une donne tout
à fait correct et qui devrait malgré son
âge tout à fait consciente de ce qu'elle
faisait ce qu'elle disait et le bruit
court vite dans la petite commune entre
discrétion et enthousiasme les habitants
imaginent comment investir cette
soudaine entrées d'argent
moi je me suis dit que c'était une bonne
occasion pour le village de pouvoir
faire des petits travaux j'espère que ça
pourra servir pour l'école pour un peu
de rénovation de choses comme ça ce
serait pas mal certain qu'ils en parlent
je pense que
voilà les gens je pense qu'ils
s'inquiètent un peu de savoir ce qui va
être fait avec cet argent pour la
commune le maire actuel ne souhaite pas
se représenter la prochaine équipe aura
la responsabilité de gérer la nouvelle
fortune de gilles launay